c'est dans la salle séchoir à piton
saint-leu que s'est déroulée la première
représentation publique de nous deux
villes où vivent un spectacle réalisé
par le groupe les flamboyants composé de
personnes en situation d'handicap
une action organisée avec l'équipe
socio-éducatif du département
les personnes fréquentent des ateliers à
la fréquence et deux fois par mois
donc tous les quinze jours où il ya on
se réunit dans une salle travail sur
l'expression corporelle et de là est
venue l'idée de monter cette pièce
tous les ans nous présentait les pièces
ans lors du repas de fin d'année et
c'est à nous allons montrer à un public
mixte pour bien montrer bas c'est quoi
le handicap et ça concerne tout le monde
dans la chanson est bien entendu les
paroles donc c'est bien ça une
performance pour ses 18 saint leusiens
qui se sont surpassés pour mener à bien
leur projet un projet de pièce de
théâtre sur lequel il travaille depuis
2013 en partenariat avec le ccas bien le
sympa et avec l'intervention de l'ex
quart d'heure de l'association baba sy
fy il existe ce que j'ai fait c'était
des déblocages de la timidité et déjà un
d'être bien avec soi-même s'aimer soi
pour se faire aimer par les autres voilà
tout repas entrecoupé de chants chacun
est venu à l'avant de la scène raconter
son histoire
handicapé un innovant n'y aura rien et
au fait qu'on croit mme annick rien
contre moi même nous donner vie à écrire
des phares comme depardieu papier mais
sa maladie on fait année
nicky à ce que cette prime il y fait il
faudrait se meut pertes
ils ont rendez vous aujourd'hui
mais ils ont maintenu en tant qu'un des
deux mondes - a grandi bien de chanter
lui faire la musique bien dans ces
médiateurs que même si dans mon corps
humains midh et le chemin il n'y a qu'un
homme soit important qui a permis à ces
personnes en situation de handicap de
devenir acteurs de leur projet sur le
plan individuel et collectif
l'objectif justement était de valoriser
la personne à travers un support telles
que le théâtre est donc je pense qu'ils
se sont en sortie
je pense au bien un objectif atteint qui
a mené ces personnes à s'exprimer devant
plus de 150 personnes dont leurs proches